Andy no tweets multiple cars in Ladera
Heights Los Angeles vandalized with
swastikas setting off fears a white
supremacist was targeting the black
majority neighborhood antifa helped
bring attention to the incidents last
week Robert haymore was arrested he's a
37-year-old black male nice what the guy
who committed white supremacy was a
black male yes and so there there are a
lot of stories like this there used to
be a thing called like the uh was it the
hate crime hoax map yeah like there were
so many that were Pro and debunked that
this is what you get I feel like the
modern state of American politics is
regular people and like people like us
are just desperately trying to figure
things out and keep things together and
then you have conservatives who are in
alignment to a great degree with that
but want more traditional values and are
willing to have those debates and the
farle who was completely lying about
everything and calling for like murder
and Terror and you name it and that's so
like one of the most sick things about
when you finally kind of realize that a
lot of the hate crimes are faked and
that there is this like demand and a
supply that isn't meeting the demand is
then you start to question a lot of
things cuz it's like okay so you have
this entire ideology structured around
who's the oppressor who's not and as
we've established we know that that's
they're warped in their sense of that
but it's like that's the Telltale sign
right there and they never truly address
how many are faked either I mean I feel
like once a week there's like you know
gay man has you know the anti-gay fur on
his car and then it's like his cousin
comes out and says he put that on there
and then no one addresses it ever again
what was like the the Bubba Wallace one
where it was like the G the garage pole
and they're like it's a news and the FBI
went out there to
investigate tax dollars at work ladies
and gentlemen sort of it's your your
fractional Reserve banking system
stripping your resources away from you
so they can go investigate a garage pull
rope Jesse smallet is really the only
example I can think of on the top of my
head where like you know know people
Everyone kind of had to call out the BS
eventually but people hung on as long as
they could no but they a lot of people
never apologized for that oh no remember
remember uh uh uh when Ellen Page went
on was it co bear whatever and was like
screaming like and it's just like bro
the whole thing was fake and it was
plainly obvious to most people and then
she had her own little Rainbow JY SM at
moment she said that she was in West
Hollywood the gayest well now now we're
talking about Elliot page oh I'm sorry
different I'm I'm the one that call um
but she had her own little wannabe
moment because these actors need to stop
writing their own stuff oh my God how am
I the worst one how am I the worst one
um zzm said uh no but okay Elliot wow
call that person it shouldn't be the
that person said that they were accosted
in West Hollywood by someone who
screamed I'm going to gay bash you so
they can't even make it believable Jesse
Smet is like Chicago attacked by
trumpers and Elliot paage is saying
someone was homophobic in West Hollywood
and if you ever been there every Street
rainow Station and like someone saying
something so specific pretty sure when
you're going to get gay bashed they
don't tell you they're going to do it
they just do it yeah it would have been
like like in West Hollywood of all
places of all places that's that's you
could have at least said Compton you
could have at least said you went down a
wrong Street downtown LA and be like it
would have been like if the people who
did that to like that supposedly did it
to SM smette said like I'm going to do a
racism
exactly I'm going to do a racism on
country but they said this is Maga
country come on weho isn't exactly
straight country Elliott but you know
taking advantage of the fact that people
don't know just how cold that 16 degrees
below zero is in the midwest that time
of year thought that but but also the
area where Smet was is like a non mostly
non-residential area it's like B next to
a bunch of corporate offices and so like
me because of that me and my friends
would skate down there because no one's
there to yell at you so when I heard
that story right away I was like what he
was by the NBC building like right
that's how I felt when I saw the Elliot
page off I'm like the rainbow Street
someone said they're going to get okay
okay I mean it's it's but it's it's also
sad though because people really are
even though it's rare victims of that
kind of stuff and it's so horrible to
lie about considering the big news
that's happening now with like Israel
Palestine forgive me friends but it is
very difficult to believe them when
they're like Israel is indiscriminately
doing all of these things I'm like I
just you know man look I don't know
because it's it's a long it's an on 75
year conflict and longer than that
technically going back thousands of
years but all I can say is the left lies
about everything so sorry there's
something bizarrely impressive though
about their dedication to a narrative
that like we said that Supply doesn't
meet that demand they'll make it meet it
they will make it they will artificially
inflate thing they'll make it so there's
something bizarrely sickly impressive
about it but it's also financially
beneficial for the media who become
useful idiots for those types of you
know at the at the lowest end of the
spectrum they're the people that are
just uh they're just doing what they're
told and it's what the it's what the
media wants from it and then the worst
are the activist reporters who are happy
to kind of obis the truth in the in the
S you know for the sake of spinning a
narrative a certain way and there's
money to be made from it in that
direction not just social change yeah
it's very clickable obviously Elliot
page a costed really clickable by the
way that speaking of which that if I
remember correctly so just don't go I
believe there was a book coming out at
that
time there's always the like we we kind
of we call it like the uh the bad
decision to Memoir Pipeline on our show
cuz it's a lot of celebrities right they
they do bad things in their 20s which
they're celebrated for their 30s come
around the rolls start to dry up well
what is it now it's book time so they
have to write a book I wrote a book it's
coming out uh tomorrow actually and and
I have to tell you this very horrifying
story Ian told me that he was selling me
an unlimited soul ring but it was a
revised soul ring that was never the
same after that yeah never the same I
kept the unlimited one for myself nerd
nerds around the world are outraged you
must buy the book if you want to see the
F there's no book I'm kidding you should
write a book that' be good it's good
timing the way I believed that coming
out you could probably write like a nine
page book and sell like 100 million
copies I was 10 million copies you must
buy my book to understand just how wrong
I was it really is the thing though now
like we we cuz what we read these
stories and I'm just like I get through
the first par and I'm like last
paragraph when does the book come out oh
it comes out in a month that's perfect
they have to just in time to go on their
media tour right cuz if you really
wanted to raise the alarm about
homophobes running through the street
right you would have done it a lot
sooner than the week your book's coming
out because he said that that was like a
couple years prior I'm like so maybe
waren the other LGBT people they're
going to get bashed on that street
before that right what if Jesse Smet was
like look I don't even have a book
coming out why would I
lie right and he's he's in trial and
it's like the defense says he doesn't
have a book coming out and they're like
oh well this man's innocent right it
really happen then damn proves it the
racism or I guess the black and white
gay straight stuff over the last seven
years six years feels like cake like
icing on the cake they we don't need it
like now that this is going off in in
Israel and even Putin's like yo this is
insane protect the women and the
children you guys kind of mentality and
maybe he maybe he's not but I don't
think he's going in and executing women
and and kidnapping children I don't
think that's the Russian they want land
so it's like I I think it's almost as if
I mean and and then John Kirby was John
Kirby the uh speaker what is his house
White House spokesperson John Kirby
announced the funding for Ukraine's
quote coming near to the end of the rope
we're done we're done funding it Ukraine
it's over well they got a phone call and
they said guys we we we got to fund
Israel it's like all right that's
exactly what's happening they're like we
need to Red diert funds into what really
matters a lot of people think the the
principal motivator for Ukraine is not
actually geopolitics
energy gas it is the military industrial
complex needs to spend money yes needs
needs to be get given contracts and so
after Afghanistan they're like what do
we do quick we need another War they
Lobby for it yeah now that Israel's
heating up they're like o okay we don't
need Ukraine anymore guys uh zinski
you're on your own there was that tweet
it said zilinsky just became America's
side
chick right that's that's pretty
accurate oh Ukraine y don't be surprised
if the US is backing away now current
thing I don't necessarily think will be
like a religious War I mean who cares
what you call it but if there's a World
War like where where uh Egypt and Israel
and the United States and Germany and
India all go to war with China and and
uh Iran and and and all these Russia is
the center lynchpin of all of this
wherever Russia goes wins so we need
them on our side they're in the center
of it all and that was what was so
demented about the Trump presidency how
like demonized he was for a attempting
to have a somewhat cordial relationship
with Putin yeah it's like mhm you can
see a drop of their argument with like
okay there's certain things to criticize
but you definitely don't want them
against you right no definitely not and
they they've had a lot of issues with
this as well with in CIA and within the
fact they were in Afghanistan as well
back in the 80s so I don't know I'm
surprised he even came out and said
anything I could see a war breaking out
and then it goes really bad for the
Americans and the Israelis half of
Israel God forbid is whatever the worst
case Ario and Putin watches and they
stay neutral and they watch and then it
gets to a point where the Arabs do some
horrific things to humanity and Putin
can no longer sip by and he joins the
Americans and then ends the war that's
what I said last night the thing I'm
most afraid of is is that the Shia and
Sunni are able to get past their their
their Collective aggression towards each
other and say like we have to deal with
Israel that's the thing that I'm most
concerned about what what is what is the
root of their aggression towards each
other do you know sh and Sunni disagree
who is a spiritual successor on Earth of
Muhammad who is a prophet and that's
because his daughter Fatima was that her
name uh no had many I don't know it was
basically it was like his brother gave
had a had a group I think it was his
brother and his daughter they have yeah
they have theyve disagree with the
lineage of who is the spiritual I think
it was his brother or it was one of his
generals or was like one of his main
disciples or something like descends
from from that man and then the other
disciples come from the daughter and
could be I'm pretty sure that's what it
is they want to speak out of turn no no
that's understand it's it's very
complicated so it's similar to like how
the ARA how the Muslims and the uh Jews
came out of Abraham's children Isaac and
Ishmael both had their tribes and same
within Islam there was two tribes that
came from Muhammad thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 800m and become a member over
at Tim cast.com for uncensored
membersonly shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time